[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sport du week-end avec miquel et demi
d'euros bonsoir en soit la rédaction de
tv 78 ton commence par du football
on jouait la coupe de france jouée ce
week-end le 8e tour de la compétition
versailles derniers représentants et
binoy encore en course va continuer
l'aventuré
les versaillais ont réussi à s'imposer 3
buts à 0 sur le terrain de dire une
équipe qui évolue également en nationale
3 les trois buts ont été inscrits par
l'attaquant yoan akassou en écoute
l'entraîneur de versailles youssef
chebbi qui retient avant tout l'état
d'esprit c'est une compétition
particulière ou puis en avant d'un pue
ça devient difficile et plus on a besoin
de deux valeurs comme comme le courage
l'abnégation la solidarité pour pouvoir
franchir les paliers et aujourd'hui en
termes de cohésion et solidarité
mon équipe a franchi un pas et
aujourd'hui ben alors là le résultat de
ce travail de ce parcours puisque on a
six matchs cette saison de coupe de
france
et si qualification consécutive cette
qualification est une première en dix
ans pour les verts c'est lié au prochain
tour versailles pourrait affronter un
club de ligue 1 au mois de janvier le
tirage au sort aura lieu ce soir grégory
on espère voir pourquoi pas un
versailles psg mickaël versailles
marseille au stade mont boron le célèbre
de versailles également du volley ball
au programme ce week-end un match pour
rester dans la course à la montée vélizy
recevez saint-avertin les derniers du
classement pour le compte de la 7ème
journée de nationale 3 bien en place
tactiquement les béliziens remporté les
deux premiers sets sur les scores de 25
22 et 25 21
dans le troisième set les joueurs de
florent guillossou sont plus en
difficulté il arrive finalement à
l'emporter 29 à 27 après avoir failli
concéder le set bilan de cette rencontre
trois sets à zéro sur le troisième set
il ya eu
un réveil de l'équipe adverse nous a pas
facilité la tâche qui a bien servi nous
on a fait des petites des petites
erreurs un peu un peu bête et ballon qui
tombe sans que personne se jettent
dessus et c'était compliqué on a su à la
fin resserrer les vis cette victoire
permet à l'équipe d'occuper la troisième
place du classement avec un bilan de
cinq victoires en sept journées
disputées des résultats qui permettent
au club de regarder vers le haut du
classement
grégory merci michael ces résultats bien
d'autres choses encore dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est à suivre
après ce journal